let's bring in Peter King from NBC
Sports and his great Monday column
football morning in America Pete let me
start with that the worst loss of the
weekend was turned in by who I would say
the Rams not because of the meaning of
it they're still going to get a bye in
the first round of the playoffs whether
they're 1 or 2 but it was just a lot of
a lot of scars showed this weekend for
the Rams could they play in a
cold-weather game could they block a
great defense you know it when you're
when you're running up and down the
field against the Kansas City Chiefs
when they've got a bunch of guys hurt
that's one thing but they played a team
at full throat the you know the Chicago
Bears and they didn't handle the
pressure well and not only you know as I
wrote this morning wasn't only the
pressure from Akeem Hicks and Khalil
Mack I mean there's pressure coming from
everywhere sort of leaking through and
so I thought that was a that was a poor
performance by them and not a great
harbinger of what's to come
yeah I guess I looked at it as Jerrod
golf now back-to-back weeks and I've
said yeah all season long I I think
their success is really predicated on
how he plays and I you know whether
that's fair to him or not it feels like
that's still the question mark that I
have weekend and week out is that fair I
would agree I would agree with you and I
think that I think you know that's one
of the things that sort of colors what
everybody does when they pick an MVP you
know there's been I don't know there's a
lot of people who who don't necessarily
think that it should just be the
province of a quarterback you know what
the fact is the quarterback is the most
valuable player in all sports it's hard
to imagine let's say in the case of
Aaron Donald even if he had played great
last night and they won I just it's very
hard for me to put a defensive tackle on
that list because it's not
called the most outstanding player it's
called the most valuable player and I
think that if Sean Mannion has to play I
think he's their backup quarterback yes
and it's hard for me to imagine they're
the greatest show on grass without Jared
Goff right now explain to me what's
going on with the Steelers if you can oh
yeah I wish I could dance like that
feeling is my gut feeling is that this
is a team that really predicates so much
so much of their success is predicated
on being able to run the ball and being
able to because Ben Roethlisberger is
not a guy who gets out of trouble very
much he's a guy who's a lumbering big
guy
you need to have a very good running
game and be you need to have the ability
to get the ball to your backs in space
so they can make big plays and they have
that with you know James Conner
obviously this year and they had it for
five years before that with with Le'Veon
Bell so I think without both of them
they start the game at a severe
disadvantage and I also think that one
of the things that's happened to them is
that yeah I think this has been the case
for most of Mike Tomlin years at least
for most of his year since Troy Polamalu
was gone anyway they really have a hard
time defending the deep ball and they
haven't had good fortune in the draft
getting corners so I think that they ran
up against the team yesterday a team
that can throw DB even a team without
Amari Cooper because Derek Carr likes to
throw the ball deep and so those are a
couple of things I didn't watch that
game closely yesterday but that's what
I've thought about them for the last two
or three weeks so the Steelers have a
tough loss nobody had a tougher loss
than the Patriots and now the Steelers
host the Patriots coming up next weekend
how do you think this plays out that's a
good question
I mean it's it's odd in the first place
that these teams meet in the same week
at the same time at the same place as
they did last year you know the Jesse
James Bowl and I really think it's a
pick'em game whatever I have no idea
what the line is but I think this is
just extremely close it's going to be a
desperation win for the Steelers to get
off the schneid and for the Patriots
there's still one game away I I just
don't think the Patriots entering this
game can be as desperate as Pittsburgh
is I know Parcells already used to say
the desperate team usually wins and I
think the Steelers are going to be a lot
more desperate to win this this way
talking to Peter King NBC Sports and it
is great column it's must read its
football morning in America how do you
explain what the Patriots did at the end
of that game I think they made a mistake
I mean if you look at what happened at
the end of that game this is not a Hail
Mary situation when Ryan Tannehill
released the ball he was standing at his
21 yard line
or 31 I think was there was it there no
he was standing on his 21 but I think
the life the line of scrimmage was the
31 yeah but the the thing about what
happened in the Patriots is that I agree
they Devin McCourty should have been on
the field he's the most trustworthy
defensive back on that team the fact
that he wasn't on the field is a is a
mistake obviously but I would just say
this still at all you know
- that is a that is a 1 in 500 shot that
that's going to work it just is it and
as much as you want to say boy Belichick
slipping or such I mean you know you got
you got 11 guys out there who can't make
a play really probably seven guys who
can't make a play
and it just that's the kind of thing
that always really surprised me but even
credit to the dolphins because they
practice this every Saturday I talked to
Kenyan Drake about it afterwards and he
said you know this is what happens when
you practice something a lot and we've
been practice and it basically since I
got here
the amazing thing then is what Drake
told me after the game we're almost
finished they had maybe 10 minutes with
him on the phone we're almost finished
and right at the end he said to me you
know when I walked into this building
when I first got drafted in 2016 the
shook hands with coach gates and he said
we drafted you to be the New England
Patriots in theory is that and so that's
he is he I guess if he never plays
another down form he's kind of paid off
you mentioned in your column that it was
five weeks ago that the Cowboys lost to
the Titans on Monday night and since
then they won by seven three eight three
and six points you know they got the
right formula here you got that defense
is you know improved and you got the
ground game here you don't have to rely
on a quarterback throwing forty times
you got at the cold so you got the
Buccaneers out the Giants handicap the
Cowboys the rest of this season well
they're gonna win the division obviously
they get a two-game lead with at least
one not easy but one game that they
clearly ought to win and that's Tampa
Bay at home but then after that they got
two intriguing games I mean the Giants
all of a sudden they're sort of a
strange team and the Colts are gonna
need that game more than the Cowboys
needed believe it or not so I think
that's they gotta they don't have an
easy road you know so they'll probably
be the fourth seed I would guess but the
thing that intrigues me about Dallas I
was I went to visit Matt Millen who you
probably knows awaiting a heart
transplant we were just talking about
football and
so he watches everything you know he
he's watching everything he's reading
books and he's sitting there you know
sort of drum you know just just kind of
waiting in this Hospital in New Jersey
one of the things he said was he just
could not stop talking about Layton van
duration and Jaylon Smith and as I as I
have said I mean he thinks that they're
the best two linebackers playing in
tandem in football right now and when
you have two guys in the middle of the
field who are sideline to sideline clay
makers it negates so much of what an
offense can do I think that's what's
happening with Dallas right now they're
getting the table set by two very young
guys on defense as much as they're
getting the table set by Ezekiel Elliott
we look at the Heisman Trophy Award and
we're waiting for signature moments do
we do the same with the MVP in the NFL I
don't I mean I I always look at this I
mean I'm right in my column every week
basically the season ended today who
appears oh I'd give it two and I deal
with the Patrick no homes today two
weeks ago I would have given it to Drew
Brees but obviously the season has to be
taken in its entirety I think you do
yourself a disservice if you rely either
on emotion a recency bias because a game
in week two means the same as the game
in week 16 so having said all that I
mean I know how I vote for it I don't
quote is who's the hot hand in December
I mean but if a guy has the hot hand in
December and leads his team teeth to the
playoffs or to the promised land or
something you know that probably is
going to mean significant something but
right now we would you know I I think
it's I think it's mahomes
Brees then probably rivers and then
after that I think it's a pretty big
mishmash Pete good stuff is always great
Reed and thanks for joining us they
really appreciated they and have a great
week that's Pete King NBC sports
football morning
in America for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]